[Applause]
promoting welfare of humanity
has been the driving force of these
talks
the question has not been what is good
for one side or the other
the focus has been on what matters most
for the people of our world
and let there be no doubt this is an
agreement for the world
it will bring relief for developing
countries on the edge of bankruptcy and
the most vulnerable people on the edge
of famine
and it will help stabilize global food
prices which were already at record
levels even before the war
through nightmare for developing
countries
specifically the initiative we just
signed opens a pass
for significant volumes of commercial
food exports from three key ukrainian
pores in the black sea
odessa
chevonnorsk and uznee
the shipment of grain and foodstocks in
world markets will help bridge the
global food supply gap and reduce
pressure on high prices
since the war started i've been
highlighting that there is no solution
to the global food crisis
without ensuring full global access
to ukraine's food products and russian
food and fertilizers
today we took important steps to achieve
this objective
but it has been a long road
in april
after
being received by president erdogan
i met with president putin and president
zielinski to propose a plan for
solutions
and we have been working every day since
it took immense efforts and commitment
by all sides and weeks of
around-the-clock
the commitment and dedication are even
more vital today
this initiative must be fully
implemented because the world so
desperately needs it to tackle the
global food crisis
we are proud to be instrumental
in an initiative that will play a major
role in solving the global food crisis
that has been on the world's agenda for
a long time
with the text agreed upon today
um from africa to the middle east from
america to asia
we will contribute together to
preventing the danger of a hunger that
billions face from all over the world
[Music]
ensuring world security of supply in
agricultural and food staff is important
in many aspects
with this step taken possible additional
soaring prices caused by the loss of
field to be caused by a current heat
wave and drought will be prevented
we are also helping with controlling
food inflation which has become a global
problem i would like to take this
opportunity to thank his excellence at
president zielinski and his excellency
president putin for their leadership
with the vessel traffic that will start
in the coming days we will offer a new
airwave for breathing from the black sea
to many countries worldwide
distinguished friends about four months
ago
again in istanbul
[Music]
negotiations were held between ukraine
and russia and we made progress back
then
and this raised hopes that the war would
end
unfortunately the developments that took
place after that meeting fueled the
conflicts
we have been saying from the very
beginning that there will be no winner
in this war
that not only the parties but the whole
world will suffer losses
this
joint step we're taking today in
istanbul uh together with russia and
ukraine
will be a new turning point
that will revive the hopes for peace
this is my sincere hope
whatever direction the developments on
the field would take the war will
finally end at the negotiating table